let me say in other words and let me
know if this is correct so that i make
sure that we're on the same page goal
versus values is akin to when sometimes
people say you shouldn't be
objective oriented versus process
oriented
is that akin to that or is that
different that's it's kind of similar
yeah it's kind of similar okay so that's
a great question right there are you
coming up with them are you realizing
them so are you making them
are you uncovering what was there anyway
that's a sub question that doesn't sound
like an easy process
so how can you help someone through that
process what tips do you have
for people to realize their own values
in the example you gave the
potential was that i want to help people
that's why i want to go to medical
school but it also may just be i want
the status but i think i want to help
people or i want the money but i think i
want to help people or actually this was
instilled in me as a child and it's
actually not my own i don't even care
but that takes to me that sounds like
that may take months or even years of
therapy so how does one streamline that
approach to get to one's values
that's a really good question and i
actually struggled with this
for a long time actually like
you know it seemed like such a broad
question to me like what are your values
well
it's tough right um
and i remember like having this aha
moment you know
and
well there are many ways to get to it
but i had this aha moment
which broke down values into like
how do i want to be in this moment
how do i want to be like okay i'm with
you right now kurt
so i check in with myself and i say
what do i want to be how do i want to be
in this moment
with this person you know
so it makes it a little bit more
concrete to me you know
but it's also that
but it also needs to be a little bit
more broad and i'll give you a very
personal example from my life like
um so i'm you know i'm a working mother
and
balancing my career with being the kind
of mother i want to be
can be very challenging you know
and so
for example i go to work let's say from
eight to five
and as i get up off my desk
um kurt
and i'm walking out the door right
there's a lot of anxiety
because
my colleagues are still there
i still have a lot of things on my to-do
list right i have a lot of things on my
to-do list
my career is very important to me
um and so when i get up at 5 00 pm to
leave and all my colleagues are still
there and my boss is still there and i
still have a lot of things on my
checklist
i'm
anxious and
i connect with
the value of what i want to be as a mom
and i want to be a mom that's available
for a certain number of hours every
night
with few exceptions
because that matters to me
so i carry the anxiety i have about my
career but what helps me walk out the
door
is see is kind of knowing that my son is
on the other side right
so sometimes it's just a matter of like
you know filling out questionnaires or
like just you know people asking you
certain questions about what are your
priorities in life right
but i see a lot of people just
on automatic pilot right on automatic
pilot doing things like they always have
staying at work
long hours barely seeing their parent
you know their children
and they say
they say like for example the patient
that like works double shifts
then goes to the bar
takes out a picture of his children and
shows the people at the bar like here's
my child and love my child so so much
goes home hungover
and when the kid comes to talk to him
pushes him away like no no not now i'm
hungover
we can talk about what matters
right i can say
my son matters i can say
my parents matter to me
my sister matters to me but if i don't
put it into an action
it means nothing
it doesn't mean anything
and so
let me give you another example sure
kur if i asked you
if i said
there's a building on fire outside and i
want you to run into it
what would you say to me
no no
thank you you would say no appreciate
that
thanks for the offer yeah yeah what if i
said to you
a loved one you have is in that building
yeah
what would you say then yeah which loved
one but i understand yeah so if it's my
wife i'll go in a second
okay
it shifted from an automatic no
to an automatic yes
because there was the why
the question is why would i go in there
what would be the purpose
and the purpose is
your partner right right
and so when you're is it going to be
easy is it going to be non-threatening
it's going to be awfully hard and it's
going to be life
threatening right
and yet you are willing
to experience
the fear the dread the anxiety that it's
going to take to get into that building
because there's something there that
matters to you
so that's
the acceptance piece acceptance is not
just saying okay i accept i accept you
know what i feel here
it's that i'm willing to feel what there
is as i move towards something that
scares me
earlier we had a little discussion about
should versus values and you were saying
kurt
well we didn't explicitly have this
discussion but you said perhaps
you
shouldn't think in terms of should i
know that's paradoxical but you
understand what i mean that in terms of
thinking of choice it's better and i'm
unclear how values don't imply it should
so if you have a high value
to me a should comes in because it's
you're doing what's right now it's what
you're saying that the value is somehow
internal and the [ __ ] is somehow
external and it should come from should
it should come from you or
i it's a bit difficult for me to say
without using the word should so yeah
hopefully you understand the question i
mean it could be just an issue of
linguistics right like it could be just
the terminology we're using but
values are freely chosen
from from an act perspective values are
freely chosen it's not what
our parents tell us
we should want it's not what i feel
society
wants me to say right
in the definition of values it is freely
chosen
and one indication
that
someone is not living a life
that's consistent with kind of what they
want
is there's a lack of vitality like you
don't sense vitality in what
someone is doing right
it feels more like it's
being imposed that it's like i have to
do this right or
i don't want to be doing this or you're
just not
you're not vitalized right
so back to my example with work
sometimes i feel like giving personal
examples helps if it's too much tell me
but like no the more personal the better
you know every time i get really
frustrated with my job
with my work with my career
i step back and i ask
do i choose this
no one's forcing me to do this work i
don't have to do this work
do i choose this work
and that helps me a lot
with the full recognition that i choose
a package that i can't just choose the
things i like
and
throw away the things i don't like
because everything we have in our life
is a package of
you know the things you like and then
the things that you have to do because
you know it's part of the broader
package
so maybe that's kind of what you're
talking about with this should like okay
doing this work i really have to write
certain notes and i have to like do all
this bureaucratic crap bureaucratic
stuff um
that said do i choose the package
that this as a package
is something i care about
that working with these patients doing
this research makes this other tough
stuff worthwhile
interesting
one of the reasons i was bringing that
up is because
i know there's a heavy emphasis on an
internal locus of control it's called
internal locus of control i believe
and then that to me sounds like to get
philosophical like the humanist movement
and then
that stands in contrast to religious
movements especially of the west where
the west is more about there are some
commandments you should follow you need
to follow but then to many people their
religion
is what they value so their value comes
with the shoulds in that case and then
our is one to say well if you're
christian or if you're
muslim or jewish because those are the
western traditions if you're those then
perhaps
you need to abandon your religion in
order to properly apply act therapies
that you have the internal locus of
control it comes from you it doesn't
come from god you choose it no i don't
think that was what was lurking
underneath
i don't think so i think if you choose
a spiritual like a spiritual tradition
you're choosing that you're choosing the
pattern right it's like stepping
yeah again like you're you're talking
again about a very concrete thing that's
like more goal
like that okay so i'm going to church
check
right that's a goal i'm going to go to
church
check and goals can be very valuable to
like tell you if you're on the right
path
towards something you value right
but the broader value if someone is
you know maybe religious now some of
them are of course some people are doing
it out of compliance right
absolutely
and then other people absolutely are
doing it because spirituality is a
broader
domain
is valuable and the specific
goal if you want or package that they
choose is
a christian or jewish or muslim right
like
the broader thing is that they are a
spiritual person and
that the goal they have is to fulfill
certain obligations within that
spiritual tradition it's like
me i love what i work or what i do
and as part of that i have to i actually
have to do certain things like check you
know i have to do certain trainings i
have to fill certain cmes so on so forth
some bureaucratic it's the values part
that's
that you don't have to
that you that that's chosen
the goals are the kind of the posts
along the way that you can say okay
check did that i know i'm on the right
track i understand yeah
what separates people
for who this works for
quickly or
plenty from those who
it takes a longer time to work for it
works less for is it their temperament
is it their attitude is it
the application of a certain technique
the amount that they stick with it for
example yeah
that's a really good question and i
think it's it's complex it's hard
because
for decades
in our field we have been trying
to do these matching studies right where
okay we're going to match this kind of
person with this kind of therapy
you know um
like this person would do better with
this therapy this person would do better
with this therapy and despite
millions of dollars being you know
committed to this kind of research
we don't really have a good answer to
that question not just for act but for
really a lot of the therapies like we
have not been able to figure out what's
what's the thing that
you know matches people like why would
this work for someone
that said
in the meta-analysis of the
meta-analysis of act studies and some of
the comparison studies what we know or
what we found is that
people who have
suffered longer tend to do better in act
right
and people who have
complex
difficulties tend to do better with act
why do you think that is
it's a good question
so
my thought on this and i don't know that
there's any data behind this
but in act there's a very key concept
called creative hopelessness
okay
and the idea behind creative
hopelessness is
okay like let's say you have anxiety
right
and i ask the person
who has anxiety
how long have you had this
and they'll say
15 years what have you tried well i've
tried
alcohol
i've tried drugs i've tried medications
i've tried
avoiding
i've tried deep breathing
i've tried meditating like i've tried it
all
okay and how has that worked
um hasn't worked in terms of reducing
the anxiety okay
and and how has it worked in terms of
like where you are with your life and
how big your life is
and they'll say
well maybe
it's it's really kind of gotten smaller
in my life
so what we do with creative hopelessness
is explore with the person
how long they've had the problem all the
techniques they've used
and if they've gotten anywhere with
these techniques in the long term
and
what what what the result is is the
patient being like oh my gosh i've been
doing this for
years and years and years and i'm worse
off than when i started
this it's called creative hopelessness
because
there's a hopelessness to it
but in that moment it gives you the
opportunity to say
okay i think i need to try something
different
this has not worked
it's like it's like up in front of your
face that it has not been working you
know you've laid it out and that
everything you've been doing has not
been working
and so
the creative part is that there's this
pivotal moment
it can be a pivotal moment where and
i've seen it happen countless times i
see it in my
you know my participants my clients eyes
like there's a pivotal moment that's
like oh my gosh this is not working
so i need to try something else right
this sometimes requires
a long time of suffering right like so
that's why sometimes i think it
resonates because
for some people they've tried for
example distraction and it's worked
temporarily and they've only had it for
a few months and they're good to go so
you know it's fine
but for people who've had it for a while
this resonates there's this pivotal
moment where they're like ah okay
okay it sounds like they've tried plenty
and then they're thinking well i need to
try something new but that something new
could be almost any of the therapies
that are tried and you said that act
seems to work better for these people
who have tried plenty already so what is
it because if it's this pivotal moment
then would that pivotal moment not apply
to any of the other therapies that that
they could try that are new any new
therapies
i mean again act is
it tends to be equivalent to other gold
standards right so it's not i'm not
saying it's better and i'm not i'm not
sure it's conclusive that it's better
for these people
but act is one of
it is the only therapy actually like
scientifically based one that's been
examined with you know randomized
controlled trials that has such a heavy
focus on the the values and it's it's
and it's also built on all these
you know basic science studies showing
that like thought suppression doesn't
work distraction doesn't work they come
in the rebound effect
but again the values piece is what
provides the motivation to to do the
hard work right so
the woman who has had panic attacks for
10 years and barely leaves her house
anymore
okay
and
has been to treatment and they've tried
to reduce the panic attacks
works for a bit not too long
and she's you know not leaving her house
very much anymore
her daughter is graduating
and this requires her to go
sit in a building with or in an
auditorium with hundreds of people like
the most stressful thing for someone
like this
what would motivate her to do this work
curt
as her as her daughter is on the stage
and she looks up into the seats
and she sees that her mother is there
right you make the values
front and center for the mom
do you want your daughter to see you
there
would you be willing to experience
that
feeling of overwhelming fear and anxiety
if it means that your daughter for the
rest of her life will say my mom was
there
so values make it worthwhile and it's a
really important aspect and so like a
lot of the traditional
cbt have now incorporated values into
their treatment models because we're
finding it's such a powerful piece right
but values have always been the heart of
act